all right this week we've got Oreo
flavors hmm
fake heart attack and woman-hater
something it's all one topic we say
Oriole haters flavors woman hater Oreo
flavors all my bad I mixed two really
interesting things whoa
birthday cake Oreos by far it's the best
the best one me that's like the worst
always you need to have the birthday
cake Oreos that's that's game time
holdin there we go gold that's like the
boring one thank you boy then wait have
you ever had birthday cake ones though
yeah you know what my favorite is like
my favorite ones are the Malaga the
Pepperidge Farm yeah that's not an Oreo
dude it's still two cookies with
something in the middle weight like a
wafer we get it cookie butter the way
I'm dealing they're really really good
can you guys send us okay what about
Nutter butters we're moving on I like
those
Oreo has announced that they have
released curry flavor two new flavors in
China it's in China so can you guys
China it's gonna be this cake aunt nails
sit you on chilly suit you want your
smog know it's gonna be tough and child
labor tears red bean matcha no that's
Japanese but you know it no they don't
have it yet he's kind of on the right
track long milk D No
okay you guys what part of China money
flavor child size or it's made of
children made by children oh they are
cherry cooks moon cake flavor
oh good guys know so the guests I mean
the black sesame flavor
oh that sounds pong yeah but it's not
ginger it is a fortune Oreo cookie hot
chicken wing and wasabi oh yeah ooh hot
chicken wing I really was I've I can see
what sabi the only thing he's been on
the right track is when he
oh okay I'd be interested you have to
try it it sounds like they were like a
de like pitching the idea table and
they're like okay how do we ruin this
company yeah go and that's what they
come up with or maybe they were thinking
of you know the jelly beans the bean
boozled how they came up with the [ __ ]
up jelly bean flavors maybe that's but
that was a game yeah so how do we yeah
we have 1.7 million people how do we
[ __ ] them up well they do this in in
Japan a lot they put really weird
flavors like what know like KitKat
there's wasabi KitKat there's like oh
there is wasabi kickin but that's
chocolate flavored this is like or what
like what's an Oreo it's kind of
chocolaty it's chocolate
you know that will the cookies chocolate
one thing that really changes what's
inside usually right yeah yeah yeah
fixed it's not like it seems like a
Saltine that feeling sugar Oreos are
also vegan yeah they are really yeah
it's not dairy is not nope it's a vegan
friendly snack so what is it just sugar
sugar cream wanna beets yep that's
another good actually that's the sounds
like a Chinese knockoff
cookies and it just looks just like
we're guys I I didn't like Oreo and toes
like in my late 20s really I thought
that [ __ ] was so nasty my life because I
had the golden one it seems like
chemical to me it just doesn't taste
like anything Nash it's like a sale
[ __ ] cookie with chemical middle and
then when I was a kid and they gave me a
stack I would just eat all the middle
part and then leave the cookie there she
was so opposite you would leave the
cookie yeah ate the cookie and that's
nobody how you ate the chemical part but
you cookie the thing that's just made
out of cookie [ __ ] no wonder why you
didn't like it the cookie part tastes
like like stale chem like it wasn't that
to me tasted like the Teddy Grahams
remember the chocolate
you eat it with milk I'm allergic to
milk so that's the thing is I didn't
drink all types of milk mm-hmm even
mothers did the raw milk is okay I think
okay I find a leaf you should dip some
Oreos and those mmm dude just the
Technion Oreo and dipping into the
[ __ ] milk was the best but it was
torture cuz you had to wait you never
used a spoon or a fork who the [ __ ] does
that know the spoon is brilliant you get
the whole cookie in there and the milk
but you know what happened though video
what happens when you put the [ __ ]
spoon and the [ __ ] Oreo in there you
get beat up by your friends that's the
side effect of is it oh wait you are you
ain't got no friends you good god - oh
man don't like those jobs you like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] dude you went like two
feet down everyone knows your secret she
introduced me to the greatest serial of
all time uh what is it kicks its Oreo
cereal what you just got Oreos and just
crumple it up and put in the ball like a
little mini Oreo it's like a little like
little loops of Oreos but they're made
of Oreo all-fire pick a favorite cereal
I'll have too many me too baby
raisin bran raisin bran [ __ ] raise your
brand when you get the [ __ ] small
ones in the pack yeah the last one back
there feet next to [ __ ] cheer no that
was hops is [ __ ] bomb like anything
without you kick often flake I know you
like kicks berry berry kicks anything
without sugar baby with almonds I love
all of them cinnamon toast crunch
I love balance my favorite is the milk
after all these all milk after see now
you're talking ding crunch cocoa puffs
cinnamon toast crunch
hands-down the best I grew up on cereal
that's all me mm actually don't remember
the last time I cereal it's been that
long yeah can we eat it like almost
every night it's so just crunch yeah
that's me they got strawberry toast
Christ $3 bro where you came into dad
with the price dude three bucks we're
who 9:00 to 5:00 at Rob's go check it
out it's probably a dollar Winco you
said to eat it in the first one for ours
I don't know where that is link oh it's
like oh they don't got a week over here
huh no they have one car Northwood wait
no moving on to the next it's like a
food for less Oh got it
wait equipment it evidence expire wind
Coast pretty good although all right so
next story this man he pretended to have
a heart attack just so he could be taken
to the hospital so we can eat the food
at the cafeteria Oh capture food that
good why doesn't he just go to the
cafeteria I don't know I mean this one
needed a ride don't they charge you for
that right yeah you got arrested
ambulance ride as expensive in Kentucky
you see there's this one hospital I
forgot what it was but I begged my
parents to take me there again cuz I
remember having to clam chowder and that
[ __ ] was so [ __ ] good I still have
dreams about it today but the hospital
that [ __ ] probably came from a
Campbell's can never bomb it is good for
what it is I you're talking about a guy
who always goes to hospitals that's true
it's it's good in a sad you okay
I always get [ __ ] up they're not
getting so many hospitals dude it's good
for what it if you broke your leg and
damn I'm always in the hospital for
something dude I'm my life is final
destination that you ain't never get me
though he was like how did I he died by
eating [ __ ] Oreo [ __ ] in a cereal
with me a bar used to volunteer at the
hospital I always looked at some of the
meals of the sick people and I'm all
like yeah man that [ __ ] looks good that
place was good though that cafeteria
that was pretty good
back downstairs cafeteria Oh gourmet
down as a good one man god damn
they had ribs sometimes all those
doctors have their own separate like
room where they would go and have every
time I would peek in there Michael it's
better she's hella carbs and salt and
sugar and yeah cocaine no it was good
they had like ribs type of [ __ ] take a
lobster what like fancy a [ __ ] lobster
yeah he had fancy that you sound like a
peasant that just lived around the
kingdom the doctors are like they've had
Lobster milord would you pass me a
lobster tail if you be God from me
Tiffany go back to the stables where you
belong and you just wish to get a little
bit of scraps I know all right I can't
fill them coz that's kind of how I feel
about IKEA like iesson I've been there
just for the food because it meatballs
your mom yeah and it's so cheap and
because it's only like a dollar or
something it's hella good in the drink
sir this is lingonberry dragon drink
yeah you should get hurt and then use
the ambulance time take you to Ikea
she's fire I broke my arm we're going to
the hospital no idea they got that
delicious chocolate cake there too
yeah it's in the bin are you sure I know
I'm fine that's a hazelnut cake right
the chocolate cake is on that kick no
they got chocolate cake that's pretty
good there so it's like the one that you
make from a box but it's so delicious
well oh why is this just so good I don't
understand I cost go food cheap food is
good let's go [ __ ] fan he looks like
a faker oh you too young for a heart
attack bro
and you too skinny and he looks like his
acting ability is probably not
and they also like I kind of picture it
like the way they write it's kind of
funny because they're like he was picked
up he had this heart attack as soon as
the ambulance parked he just walked out
of the ambulance and went straight to
the cafeteria but he saw to pay for the
food oh good maybe he was like oh [ __ ]
was uber that's what it is what if he
was there like for some other reason
like maybe an ammonia or some [ __ ] and
he was like man that [ __ ] banana
pudding dude I just cannot forget I
don't like you
he's dreaming about and you have to be a
patient to eat at the cafeteria there
oh yeah that's actually a good point
it's so good what about when you had
taker
no I was just post meeting damn I lost I
don't get the Jill all the way
no more jello because you pulse made of
[ __ ] yeah I'll go to the front pick it
up and I bring it back and we eat it
together where'd you do with the legs
are broken I wasn't hungry oh yeah like
once I gave labor then that was it Wow a
head sugar fish house the first thing oh
yeah you did actually the fish yeah bad
sushi like six miles I didn't have a
c-section because I had to go on a water
diet after and then my first meal after
having Isaac I threw it all up say too
fast cuz I was too hungry and it was
only jello water diet
I was jello and I think a soup or
something like it has to be no solids
after having surgery sometimes I like
that when I get the stepped on the cake
and I have puke so much I got nothing
but Pedialyte y'all cold water why are
you you could just do that now without
getting sick but it feels good when
you're sick and then you slowly regain
your ability to have all you're talking
about like the type of sick foods and
drinks that's like the only bright side
of being sick yeah yeah I favourite
McDonald's after I had like I threw up
for seven days straight and you a
McDonald's like god damn it just
solidifies everything it's like the
first night you're the only person I
know that that happens to well cuz if I
McDonald after I just got being saying
imma throw up again yeah McDonald's is
pepto-bismol but a food form for me like
if I need something to come out solid
you're accidentally order like okay I
got a 20-piece pepto oh [ __ ]
I know exactly good I get every single
mean I get the quarter pounder with Mac
sauce I get the beef Hey
that's I know what you're talking about
cuz it's better than the Big Mac and
then I get a chicken nuggets I get
chicken 10 or 20 maybe 10 or 20 and then
complete filet-o-fish so I get some some
of the see all the nutrients you need
he said [ __ ] animals there's like is
even really real meat
so technically who knows he probably is
kind of vegan by eating McDonald's
suppose enlightened dude my last story
there's this man in Texas who has been
linked to two shootings which involved
women drivers drivers he says that he
hates female drivers so much that
they're incompetent his sole purpose is
to only give birth to male children that
he took upon himself to shoot these
women so he shot two of them in the arm
weight if they're if all women if their
job was to just give male like birth to
Mel where the [ __ ] are ladies gonna come
from
all right guys an idiot yeah so this
they're also here to annoy us but the
[ __ ] come on now yeah so this dude is 20
I'm just kidding and they keep car
insurance companies in business yeah uh
whose cars more [ __ ] up whose both
cars are more [ __ ] up than the female
I'm waiting for TIFF to tell story yeah
exactly who [ __ ] up the other person's
car cuz my Scott my car was like
scratch-free
I don't know all your vague general talk
your truck you guys what have a chat yes
should we know we're good at the chat
right here right now okay
we should those couples I love those
couples that like to ruin the mood hey
guys so we don't know yes fine this is
fine I want you to hear what you're
gonna say to me
I never robbed go ahead rob so let's
don't tell them what you've experienced
yes all the time
dudes Rob do you want to talk to us
about Rob no it's okay
I just hate that [ __ ] dude you [ __ ]
serious hey guys are you guys okay no
we're okay we're completely fine because
he called me a [ __ ] back didn't you
so it's one of those Oh once when Steve
made Nikki cry no during their podcast
doesn't it you like stop mom and dad's
Bob no I was just like wait we can leave
I just get mad at them I'm not just here
to eat dude let's go inside [ __ ] come on
shut the [ __ ] up let's go all right I
love you baby so I'm gonna show you guys
the photo of this dude's name is Nicolas
29 years old yes what'd he look like uh
what's the topic again
he shot women drivers cuz nobody wants
to [ __ ] him cuz he looks like that he
looks like he got a [ __ ] Big Mac
that's saving right there
I got Pelican yeah he's saving food yeah
he's saying that you shot these women in
self-defense because they swerved and
hit input if he was shooting them at the
gas station he was waiting for them to
pull over and a guest also was doing it
safely oh yeah smart guy shooting them
on the road so Wow got cut off he's that
guy you know like the guy that honked
yeah yeah it's just his honker I don't
know some people know like your two cars
or three cars even ahead and then you
change into their lane and they're like
you're [ __ ] cop it all yeah but
really there's like it's not that
situation it is just a trigger point to
let them feel like oh this person messed
up now I can just get everything out my
dad hates me my mom my wife hate her
that's really bad
I'm talking about like it's like it's
different it's like you're just upset
for something else we should change the
horns to say something like that
look we would use it less oh yeah I
think horns are like when you hear it's
like Oh insecurities that's what I hear
too unless they're about to hit you then
I know that because I'm the one talking
I know what if it went excuse me hello
manners I just want the gay Hornet maybe
you can switch it dude he was being held
on $200,000 bail for each of the two
charges whoa what was a murder they
didn't die but he shot at them attempted
murder attempted murder but he said it
was big what he said it was on in
self-defense that's what he was parked
at a gas station an attempted murder I'm
with you
yeah I don't know he said it was
self-defense
oh I mean the charge no he was oh yeah
I'm trying to find the target I don't
see it so yeah they're just mentioning
his bail that's [ __ ] crazy I mean
that's still a lot of money though if
it's like two women is 400,000 he also
admitted shooting at vehicles five other
times in the past he's never driven in
Monterey Park because if he did he would
he'd be like okay we're gonna cool now
Balkan Chinese people yeah you know what
about you you know what made me shut the
[ __ ] up it's like all this driving with
my mom and I was like man look at this
[ __ ] look at this [ __ ] shitty ass
driver she's all like you know what you
know who's the worst driver I'm like
what the one that complains about the
worst drivers and I'm like damn
right you're so right mom goes oh my god
my adventure if you're [ __ ] good then
you won't even that won't even thank you
thing about everyone around me I
complain like a Moute that's bar Z
because she's like she's like if you are
really good you would see them as like
oh they're still learning and you would
have patience for them and I'm like damn
I sold room Arden what if she was
yelling at you while doing this she's
upset driver she'll get you with road
rage tell her my girlfriend is the worst
driver honor that she will not admit it
she just won't [ __ ] if she should
battle her you guys would be great yes
he's quite smashing into each other baby
she's such a bad driver she is so funny
that she won't admit it to the point
where people are honking around her 24/7
you know why she goes I don't help care
people honking at me at all I was like
I'm in this car
20 people honked at you what are you
talking she was I didn't hear it doesn't
mean it didn't happen
it happened and then all sudden she just
does this and takes out your functioning
but because I'm listening
this Oh crazy dude scares
[Music]